[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the brutal murder of one woman
Sarah everard
brought to light
[Music]
the everyday violence against hundreds
of thousands of women and girls right
across this nation
but is change coming
I've been to one police force in
Southern England to find out we're at a
moment a critical moment of opportunity
they get beaten up they get raped they
get assaulted they it's they they're
they're really vulnerable I thought I
was going to die that way well you saw
he was going to kill you yeah
[Music]
violence against women and girls has
been described as an epidemic by those
on the front line trying to deal with
perpetrators and recent high-profile
cases has certainly put the problem into
public view as well as putting pressure
on politicians to act but as the former
home secretary said to me recently there
is inconsistency across different forces
in dealing with the issue so I came to
this one to find out what they're doing
Avon and Somerset police hundreds of
miles from Westminster and its lawmakers
[Music]
but the crimes here replicated
Nationwide England and Wells saw the
highest ever number of recorded sexual
offenses in the year to March
Sarah crew is the national lead for rape
and sexual offenses and the first female
Chief Constable of this Force I think
we're at a moment a critical moment of
opportunity some of the problems are the
same they're difficult they're societal
we've taken steps forward but we've also
taken steps back when you say steps
forward and steps back
can you give me just one thing that you
think is a step backwards we were
starting to make progress on
understanding as practitioners how to
tackle it for a variety of reasons not
least austerity we had to make some
choices in policing and even in Somerset
was no different from other forces and
that specialism had to retract slightly
with choices come hard consequences but
this Force now the faster pilot a new
program operation ceteria a focus on the
suspect rather than the credibility of
the victim it seems to me that often in
the discussions around sexual violence
against women and girls harassment it's
always about women these are the
behaviors you need to change in order to
make yourself safer we hear women up and
down the country
saying they want better and that's why
it's a priority but the focus needs to
be on how we're understanding those how
they're exploiting the system a system
focusing as much on girls and boys as it
does women this just won School in
Bristol being taught about the dangers
of exploitation first of all do you know
what grooming is Child Protection
Officer Andre has worked on behalf of
Avon and Somerset for almost 20 years
much of her time spent on an operation
called topaz which brings together
various agencies to focus on preventing
both the sexual and criminal
exploitation of children I think it's
getting easier for people to groom
children especially online
you don't need to go to Parks now to
find kids you go on Snapchat you go on
Tick Tock it's getting younger and
that's something I see especially after
the Corvette the online grooming is
getting younger it has now gone into
primary schools and from year three
since January Andre has taught 13
000 children of both primary and
secondary age about how to best protect
themselves so if you
want to say to you if you don't send me
a photograph of yourself naked I'd
I don't know what you need to do say bye
lessons they're learning and fast what
did you do like
not taking pictures of like yourself
when you're like naked or something
because
um they might like share the picture to
other people and post it online I found
something else last meeting was like how
dangerous how like public is these days
even like apart near my house like my
friends keep on saying that like don't
go there after seven o'clock because
apparently drug dealings happen for is
the scale of the challenge in trying to
protect children and by children you
mean under 18 year olds that's right is
it getting easier or harder are much
harder I would say because
we've got we know that exploitation
exists we work very hard to safeguard
children but in the interviewing seven
years the role of the internet has
really accelerated The Grooming process
I would say there's a greater risk now
how are we doing things differently
would you say to to the past or you
you're evolving as the threat changes
every serious case review you look at
will tell you that the key failure is
between professionals and communication
between professionals and so that's the
objective for topaz is to work with our
partners and to share as much
information as possible
hello
hello
hi I'm just booking on I'm part of the
street sex worker guardianship program
today I am working until approximately
midnight and I'm with Joe Ritchie from
bernardo's
Partners like Lucy and Joe critical to
that information sharing it's Tuesday
night and they're out on patrol in an
unmarked car in central Bristol oh is he
picking up though
he's picking you up
okay
go forward a bit just so I can get a bit
of a view of his shoes
they're working to safeguard and protect
vulnerable sex workers with a view to
gaining both their trust and
intelligence about how children are
being exploited we have always known for
years and years and years that these
areas are a hot spot for um children
being targeted for the purposes of
sexual exploitation and that is very
much because of it being an area
affected by Street sex works so there
are customers who are cycling to walking
to driving to the area with the
intention of purchasing sex and some of
them obviously will have a preference
for children
but it's always been really difficult to
get a handle on
this is a complex situation both women
and girls targeted and over half the
women working on these streets abused as
children it's a cycle so often repeating
itself it's a really really really sad
situation it's a really sad place to be
and I think the stereo type and the
stigma they've got is just
really
unnecessary and cruel really these are
vulnerable women that need
looking after a safeguarding vulnerable
women on the streets but inside homes
too which is much less visible but the
risk is just the same you all deal with
domestic abuse on a daily basis this
training course for student officers
part of a new initiative to transform
the response to domestic abuse and
increase understanding about its
variants it's got a particular emphasis
on controlling a coercive Behavior which
is a reasonably new piece of legislation
and it's about reinforcing what that
legislation is and how officers can deal
with it when they go to scenes the
victim isn't necessarily coming forward
about the details of about what's
happened it's about using the right
questions looking for the right Clues
Clues which can be hard to spot often
hidden and behind closed doors 80
percent of domestic abuse is unreported
a crime which affects a quarter of women
in their lifetime and can happen to
anyone I the problem is vast
we're probably just beginning to get to
grips of just how
how much of an epidemic it is Chief
Inspector Sharon Baker the lead on
domestic abuse for this force a victim
herself I felt that sense of
embarrassment really deeply that I was
supposed to be protecting people yeah I
couldn't protect myself
so that kept me locked in silence I was
told I was never good enough my
confidence was eroded to the point where
I doubted every decision I made I could
come to work and make decisions as a
supervisor quite critical ones and but
yet when I went home I was told that I
couldn't see that my friends were no
good for me abuse that continued for
several years but one night things
changed
words becoming threats and more when I
try to leave right when I realized it
was over and I told him it was over then
that night yeah it became physical
and I was assaulted
I called the police because I was
absolutely terrified I thought I was
going to die that night well you thought
he was going to kill you yeah
[Music]
thank you
that fear felt by women everywhere in
Bristol and far beyond women demanding
change change change
whether it happens how long it takes and
what change looks like
questions Society the police and the
justice system will need to answer Beth
Rigby Sky News Bristol